مرحبا
انا كتير فخور انه اليوم واقف هون قدامكم
بحكي عن موضوعنا كثير
فخور باني انجزته في اثناء فتره جاء احد
كورونا
اليوم مش حابب احكي لكم عن حالي بكفي
اتوقع المقدمه اللي اعطوها الشباب عني رح
احكي لكم عن امور مش موجوده لا على
الويكيبيديا ولا على صفحات الاخباريه اللي
حكوا عني اليوم راح احكي لكم عن كيف
استغليت جائحه كورونا اللي هي احدى الاصعب
الفترات اللي مرقت على الانسانيه واثرت
على مئات الملايين في الاردن والوطن
العربي والعالم وكيف استخدمتها حتى اقدر
احل مشكله انا كنت اواجهها شخصيا كمعالج
وكمختص في مجال التوحد والاضطرابات
النمائيه هاي المشكله هي مشكله التشخيص
الخاطئ اللي بتاثر على اطفالنا واطفال
المستقبل
[موسيقى]
ما بيزبط
في اثناء فتره جاء احد كورونا كلنا اجبرنا
نقعد في البيت حياتنا تغيرت مدارسنا
جمعاتنا كلياتنا كلها تسكرت لكن اكثر
الاشخاص اللي تاثروا في اثناء هذه الفتره
كانوا اطفال جائحه الكورونا الاطفال الذين
ولدوا بهاي الفتره واكثر اشي الاطفال
المصابين بالتوحد والاعاقات الذهنيه
لو طلعنا على احدث الاحصائيات رح نلاقي
انه اكثر الدول اصابه
بالتوحد في العالم هي دول عربيه منبلش في
قطر ثم الامارات عمان البحرين السعوديه
الكويت وهون عندنا في الاردن اللي حوالي
احدث الاحصائيات اوجدت انه ما يقارب
المليون و500 الف شخص حاليا هون في الاردن
مشخص بنوع معين من الاضطرابات النمائيه
وطبعا الغير مشخص اكثر بكثير هاي النسب
العاليه بتعود لاسباب كثيره اهمها انه
احنا في عنا ثقافه العيب
ثقافه العيب بتخلي انه اطفالنا يتم
تشخيصهم تشخيص متاخر بيتم تدخلات متاخره
وبرضو كمان في عنا شح المصادر اللي بنقدر
من خلالها انه نشخص الاطفال ونتدخل باسرع
وقت ممكن
اليوم راح احكي لكم عن مثال عن احد
الاشخاص تم شان تم هو الشعب غير ناطق مصاب
بالتوحد لكن بسبب توحده وبسبب انه غير
ناطق للاسف تم تشخيصه تشخيص خاطئ
بالاعاقات الذهنيه
هلا التوحد اذا تم التدخل بشكل مبكر بشكل
صحيح راح نقدر انه الطفل نعطيه فرصه يدخل
المدرسه يتعلم يدرس يتخرج يشتغل يتزوج
ويكون عائله في المستقبل وعيش حياه اشبه
بالطبيعي لكن الاعاقات الذهنيه للاسف هي
اشبه بانه كتبنا له الموت وهو عايش
تمشا هو عباره عن مثال بحب دائما احكي عنه
لما اشرح عن مشاكل التشخيص الخاطئه
مشان عانه بسبب انه التشخيص الخاطئ اللي
اعطوه اياه فقط لانه غير ناطق والطرق
الحاليه اللي بيستخدموها للتشخيص عمرها
اكثر من 70 سنه يعني لو نرجع لورا ونتطلع
على جميع
التحديثات اللي صارت للادويه والعلاجات
وطرق التشخيص في جميع المجالات الطبيه
بنلاقي في تطور كبير الا في تطور بطيء
كثير في مجال تشخيص الاضطرابات النمائيه
والتوحد
خلينا نشوف كيف هذا الاشي ياثر على تم
بكل بساطه لانه كان بيعتمد على هذا الجهاز
وهذا الجهاز في معظم المدارس ممنوع
الاطفال يتم استخدامه لانه يعتبر مراتا
او انه هو زي مبالغ فيه في بعض الاحيان
بيسموهن هي اضافه للطالب تم تشخيصه بطرق
التقييم التقليديه على اساس انه دهنيه لكن
لانه والدته امنت فيه وامنت انه هذا
التشخيص خاطئ قدرت انه توفر له فرصه انه
يتعلم الان تم عانه كثير بسبب هذه التشخيص
الخاطر كان عنده مشاكل نفسيه ادت الى انه
ممكن تؤدي للانتحار كان ممكن انه يؤذي
نفسه يؤذي الاشخاص اللي حواليه لكن بسبب
انه في شخص امن فيه وفي شخص قدر يعطيه
الفرصه قدر يبدع راح نحكي اكثر عن تم في
نها يه هذه التوك راح نورجيكم لما فعلا
نعطي الاطفال فرصه شو ممكن يصير معهم
تم بحكيلنا هون انه مش سهل مش سهل عليه مش
سهل على عائلته ومش سهل على الاشخاص اللي
بحبهم
لكن هذا الاشي مش فقط صار معتم حاليا
للاسف فيما يقارب اكثر من 70% من اطفال
التوحد بيعانوا من التشخيص الخاطئ ولو
رجعنا في الماضي راح نلاقي انه هاي
الارقام توصل لمئات الملايين ومئات من
الملايين من الاطفال اللي رح يجوا
للمستقبل راح يعانوا كمان من هاي المشكله
اللي هي المشكله التشخيص الخاطئ
ممكن تسالوا شو هو السبب تبع هاي المشكله
الاجابه بسيطه كثير اكثر ما بتتوقعوا معظم
الطرق التقليديه اللي عمرها اكثر من 70
سنه تعتمد على انه الطفل ما يكون عنده
مشاكل في النطق تعتمد على ان الطفل ما
يكون عنده مشاكل سلوكيه وبتعتمد على انه
الطفل ما يكونش في عنده طلاق تعلق زائد او
سيفريشن مع اهله بس لو فكرنا منطقيه
بنلاحظ انه اطفال التوحد 40% منهم عندهم
مشاكل في النطق معظمهم عندهم مشاكل سلوكيه
ومعظمهم عندهم تعلق زائد فاكيد لو
استخدمنا هاي الطرق التقليديه اللي صارت
لازم تكون في الماضي
راح يكون نسبه التشخيص خاطئه وبتوصل
لسبعين بالميه
في اثناء فتره جائحه كورونا كنا اجبرنا
نقعد في البيت مثلي مثلكم لكن صار في عندي
الوقت انه انا كمختص حاليا كنت وقتها في
كندا انه اقعد وافكر واصمم وابتكر واقتنع
وبدي احل المشكله اللي انا شخصيا كنت
اواجهها فصرت افكر كيف ممكن نلاقي طريقه
من خلالها نخترع جهاز نقدر نشخص الاطفال
من ابكر عمر ممكن ونعطيهم فرصه انه يحصلوا
على تشخيص مبكر
فبلشت اصمم في جهاز على ورق زي هيك هاي
الورق الاساسيه اللي اول مره برسم عليها
كنت
احتفظت فيهم صراحه اني انا كنت عارف اني
راح اطبقها وكنت عارف انه يوم من الايام
لازم اورجي كيف بلشت
فكاني حطيتها اللي هو باور اوف تراكشن او
اللي بدكم اياه
انه يوم من الايام راح اكون واقف هون
امامكم واحكي لكم عن قصه نجاح هذا
الاختراع
بلشت انه بدي الاقي طريقه ما بتعتمد على
انه الطفل يكون ناطق ما بتعتمد على انه
الطفل يكون بعيد عن اهله وتكون تلفت
انتباهه وتكون سريعه
بتصميم شوي بشع راح اعترف لكن لما بلشنا
نجمع الداتا لما كنت وقتها جمعنا بيانات
هائله جمعنا بيانات من اطفال من الاف
الاطفال وقدرنا ناخذ اللي هو الموافقه
وكمان البصمه او البروفايل من كبار
العلماء من جامعه هارفرد اللي هم عندهم
اختصاص في مجال الابتكارات والذكاء
الاصطناعي
فابتكرت اي دي اي دي هو عباره عن اول نظام
ذكي يعتمد على الذكاء الاصطناعي وقادر على
تشخيص القدرات العقليه عند الاطفال من عمر
الاربعه اشهر يعني تخيلوا معي من عمر
اربعه اشهر بنقدر نتدخل نعطي تشخيص دقيق
وتدخلات المبكره لما تكون من عمر الاربعه
اشهر فوق وهذا اشي كان اشبه بالمستحيل
سابقا لانه معظم الطرق التقليديه ممكن
تعطي تشخيص فقط بعد الاربع سنوات يعني
الطفل بيضيع اهم فتره من تطوره اللي هي
اول اربع سنوات من حياته
اي دي بيقدر يعطينا فتره او مده سريعه
اللي هو تشخيص دقيق وبما انه بيعتمد على
الذكاء الاصطناعي قدرنا انه نوصل كدقه
عاليه كثير ونزلنا نسبه الخطا السابقه
اللي كانت 70% لصفر فاصله خمسه بالمئه
[تصفيق]
تتذكروا الصوره اللي كانت قبل على ورق
صارت حقيقه صارت حقيقه سوينا الجهاز
عملناه كان عباره عن يعني سنين شغل
اشتغلنا عليه لكن بالاخير لقينا افضل
سيستم نظام نقدر من خلاله انه نلفت انتباه
الطفل عن طريق الكرتونز او الرسوم
المتحركه اللي احنا مثل اي شخص عنده اطفال
او يتعامل مع اطفال بيعرف انه عندهم تعلق
زائد بالرسوم متحركه ففكرت انه ابسط طريقه
انه اخلي الطفل ما يحس انه في تقييم ما
يحسش انه في شخص قدامه لابس وايد كوت او
اشي ببين على اساس انه هو حدا غريب مهما
كان الشخص راح يضل شخص غريب الولد مش
مرتاح له راح يكون موجود مع والده او
والدته او اكثر شخص هو مرتاح معه وبحضر
فيديو ست دقائق ونصف نقدر من خلاله نحصل
على تقييم دقيق لقدراتهم العقليه
فزي هيك بلشنا نجرب على اطفال وقدرنا نثبت
بما انه الطفل ما في داعي يكون ناطق مختلف
تماما عن الفحوصات السابقه اي طفل كان
عربي كان اجنبي شو كانت ديانته عرقوا
بيقدر يستفيد من هذا الجهاز من دون
هدفي كان انه اوصل جهاز الكل يقدر يستعمله
جميع الاعمار والكل يقدر يستفيد منه
بهذا الجهاز شاركت في برنامج نجوم العلوم
اللي هي احدى مسابقات او خلينا نحكي
مبادرات برنامج مؤسسه قطر وقدرت انه يتم
اختياري كواحد من المشتركين من الاف
المبتكرين والمخترعين العرب في الوطن
العربي وكمان وصلت للنهائيات وكنت احد
الفائزين فيه
[تصفيق]
كان فخر كثير كبير لالي انه انا اكون امثل
بلدي الاردن اكون واقف على منصه في برنامج
انا من انا صغير كنت بحلم اكون جزء منه
وكمان ينعرض على عشرات القنوات في الوطن
العربي بس مش بس مثل فيها الاردن ممثل
فيها الشباب العربي ومثل فيها اطفال
التوحد والعاقات الذهنيه واحاول احل
مشكلتهم اللي هم بيعانوا منها صار لهم
فتره طويله
اي دي هو اختراع دقيق شامل وثوري
اول ما اجيت على الاردن صار عندي هدف هدفي
انه بدي اساعد الاطفال هون عندي في بلدي
في الوطن العربي
فاسست اول مركز عربي طبي متخصص اللي هو
مركز تدخل ومبكر للتوحد واضطرابات النمو
في الاردن هون حتى اخدم اطفال الاردن
اطفال شعبي وكمان اطفال الوطن العربي
حاليا صار بيجينا بسبب هذه خلينا نحكي
الرسك اللي اخذته بدل ما اروح على كندا
صار يجينا هلا من حكومات مثل حكومه
السعوديه الحكومه الاردنيه الحكومه في
الامارات وقطر بدهم يعملوا نفس هذا
الموديل اللي احنا عملناه هذا المركز
عندهم في بلادهم حتى نقدر نستفيد بعدين
دائما بحكي للشباب مرات عم تاخد مخاطره
وتبلش عندك هون في بلدك بكون مرات بيستحق
لانه مش دائما الفرصه بتكون برا مرات
بتكون الفرصه قدامنا واحنا مش عارفين
تتذكروا تم حكيت لكم بالاخير راح احكي لكم
عن نهايه في النهايه شوي عنه لما تم
اعطيناه تشخيص الصح وامنا فيه قدر انه
يخلص المدرسه وقدر كمان يكتب في كتاب يحكي
في عن الصعوبات اللي هو واجهها بسبب
التشخيص الخاطئ
انا كنور الدين هدفي انه اعطي كل طفل في
العالم فرصه مثل فرصه تم
[تصفيق]
ولولا هذا الاختراع كان للاسف الملايين
الاطفال راح يكونوا في المستقبل بيعانوا
من هاي المشكله
انا اليوم بكل فقر مبسوط كتير انه احكي
قدامكم انه بفضل جائحه كورونا استطعت احل
مشكله التشخيص الخاطر في التوحد
حاب احكي للشباب انه دائما بغض النظر عن
الصعوبات اللي بتواجهوها سواء كانت جائحه
كورونا مشاكل عائليه ماديه شخصيه صحيه
لازم نحاول نستفيد منها ونحاول نحولها
لاشي ايجابي حتى يفيدنا ويفيد الاشخاص
اللي حوالينا شكرا
[تصفيق]